i'm going to talk today about sql and no
i'm not talking about the second part of
a movie
i'm talking about the structured query
language keep watching and we're going
to talk about how much sql you need to
be a successful data scientist
and i'm going to give you some hopefully
pretty helpful resources
i'm richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
so it shouldn't come as a surprise to
absolutely anybody
that sql is one of the highest in demand
skills for data scientists
and you're probably going to have to use
it on the job at least to some extent
now a while ago i did a video where i
laid out a study pathway for data
science
and i listed three absolutely essential
things which any data scientist must
know
and then i followed it with four other
things which are very helpful
but maybe those are optional and they
can come in order of personal preference
i put sql as the second most important
thing on that list
with the only more important thing being
statistics
yes i even put sql ahead of r or python
now why did i do that well a big reason
for that
is because sql is generally thought to
be easier to learn than r and python are
there's just less stuff in it that you
need to get really good at
it's not littered with packages that you
need to get familiar with
and you can think of it syntactically as
kind of even similar to the english
language
also to do any kind of complex analysis
you need to get your data into a usable
format first
so you're probably going to query your
data from a data warehouse or database
and that's typically going to come from
multiple different tables
but sql certainly does have some depth
to it so it's definitely worth asking
the question of how much sql
exactly do you need to know because for
the overwhelming majority of data
science jobs
you probably don't need to know
performative sql at
anywhere near the level that data
architects or database
engineers do so i'm going to step
through 10 sql items that i think are
important
and obviously this is not going to be a
comprehensive list
for every single data science job on the
planet
but for most people i do think if you
know all these items
you're going to know more than enough
sql for your daily job
and who knows maybe even you'll be able
to impress the person who's asking you
sql questions in an interview
but before i do that just a few small
requests
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and also take
one second of your time to smash the
like button
that really helps my content reach a
larger audience
also i will have a link in the
description of this video to my patreon
account
if you're willing to go and support me
that way it would be massively
appreciated
alright so we're going to start with the
absolute fundamental basics
and those are the select select distinct
from
where and order by functions and this is
the part that reads more like the
english language than anything
you select your columns from a table in
your database
where certain conditions are true that's
all there is to it
and then occasionally you'll want to
keep duplicates but sometimes you don't
if you don't want the duplicates then
you just need to throw the distinct in
there
select by default will keep all the
duplicates whereas if you do select
distinct it just eliminates the
duplicates
now the where clause is a pretty
flexible and powerful one
and it's typically going to be used with
a word like and or
or not so naturally these are going to
allow you to create the conditions you
need for filtering rows
based on the observations you have in
one or more columns
but then you've also got the like phrase
and this is going to be super critical
to have
when you're working with text and
strings now you can also use this with
wild cards
and the sql syntax for these are
percentage symbols
as they are in most languages and you
can use these to cut your text in either
direction to filter on matches
then you also have the in and between
operators
now where in will allow a column to take
on multiple different values
where between is for continuous
variables
where you want the value to fall between
one value and another
order buy is an optional addition here
and it's really not always something you
need
just because it does have a tendency to
cause some pretty serious slowdown
if you have data that's on the bigger
side having said that it is a
foundational one to know
and naturally you can use it to return
your records in either ascending or
descending order
so okay you've got your data selected
and filtered
maybe even you ordered it now next step
you've got to summarize it
and that's where the group by function
and various summary functions are going
to come into play
there's all kinds of summary functions
and i'd say the most common one
is the count function that literally
just returns a count of the number of
rows
but then some other pretty common ones
are the avg
and sum functions these are good when
you're working with continuous data
these will give you the average and the
sum respectively
but i'd wager a guess that the
overwhelming majority of the time
you don't want one summary number for
your entire data set
you want to do a grouped summary that's
where the group by statement is going to
come in
and it's going to help you to run any of
these summary metrics
grouped by unique values from another
column
and again that's the majority of the
times you'll need to run these summaries
so get very comfortable with it and also
just remember the group by
comes after the where clause i always
used to forget that
now there's also one more nuance summary
functions
can't be used with the where clause sql
has a different statement
called having for that see this
situation here
where they do a grouped count but they
only want to return the cases where the
count of customers is greater than five
so they use the having clause not a big
deal
just something you gotta remember and
that brings us to another one of the
absolute foundational items of sequel
and that is of course
joins it's very rare that you're just
going to have one
clean table you probably are going to
have multiple tables which need to come
together into one
and that's where joins come in now there
are multiple different kinds of joins
but the overall principle is going to be
the same for all of them
you're going to merge two different
tables together or at times you're just
going to have a sequence of joins to
bring multiple tables all together
and you're going to join based on a
common matching value for a column
that's in both tables
here's the main types of different joins
now inner join
is the default one and that's going to
keep only the records
in which there's actually a match in
both tables
the left join and the right join are the
exact same thing
just with a different order of the
tables and you can either keep all the
records on the left side or the right
side
and then cases where there's no match or
nulls
that's all there is to it and then i can
count on half of my one hand
the instances in which i've needed to
use an outer join
but i suppose that's a good one just to
be aware of too
it keeps all the records in both tables
and there are a couple of other types of
important joins
one that i've used a few times is called
the cross join
and this basically gives you the
cartesian product between two different
tables
it's going to spit out a table with the
number of rows equal to
the number of rows on the left table
times the number of rows in the right
table
and this is a pretty helpful tool if
you're making something like a seed
table
so it's really important to get
extremely comfortable with joins
because these are literally what sql was
designed for
you're creating a merged data set by
working with sets of rows all at the
same time
all right so now you know most of the
key functions you're able to take
different data
join it filter it group it summarize it
all that good stuff
well a lot of stuff in sql cannot be
done with just
one single query often it's going to be
necessary to run
one query store the results somehow
and then use the results of that query
to join or
filter or whatever you need to do to the
results of another query
and there are multiple ways that you can
do this and i'm going to talk about
three of them here
those are sub queries temp tables and
ctes
here's an example of a sub query and now
these are not always the easiest things
to read
but generally the best approach is to
read them from
inside out so we're going to do that
here
you've got a student id equal to v002
and we extract the column total marks
from them
then we join two tables and filter based
on that result
so we only return rows where the
students total marks
is higher than the one inside our inner
query
so we're using a result in our inner
query
to filter the results from our outer
query that's really all there is to it
now we also have what's called temp
tables and we have what's called
common table expressions or ctes
and these essentially serve the exact
same purpose that that sub query you saw
does
that is we're running one query and
we're using the results of it
we're accessing that to influence what
we're getting from some
other query i'm not going to go much
into the difference between temp tables
and ctes here
because quite frankly both of them will
work for the vast majority of problems
however it is important to know there
can be some pretty serious performance
differences between
sub queries temp tables and ctes
and honestly the specific instances
could be the subject for a different
video in and of itself
but rather than be intimately familiar
with all the situations in which one is
better than the other
i think the most important thing for
most data scientists
is just to be familiar with all the
three approaches
and be able to interchange them quickly
just to tune your query for performance
here's an example of a cte and now these
are created using the with
statement and the thing with them is you
have to immediately
access the results using a statement
like select
you can also use insert or update or
delete
but i think the majority of the time
you're just going to be selecting from
them
and you see here they create one cte
from person information data
using things like first and last name
then they create another cte
from phone number data then they join
the two
on the common business entity id now
ctes are my personal favorite of these
three methods
but again get familiar with all three of
them
temp tables are a similar idea except
you can access them outside of the
context of something like a select
statement immediately afterward
one nice thing i will say with ctes is
you can use them for recursion
to loop through your data set but i do
think that's going to be way more
advanced than what most data scientists
are going to need to do using sql
next up we have two of the most powerful
and flexible functions in sql
and that's case when and exists and i'm
grouping them together here because
together they make an incredibly
powerful combination
casewed is the equivalent of an if then
else statement that you might see in
something like python
and as you can imagine you'll use this a
lot for mapping different values of some
variable
to a different variable like in this
example where they're going from a
quantitative variable to a text string
pretty straightforward stuff exists is
typically used in the where clause
but personally i love using it with case
when
here's an example illustrating how these
two work together
and using this can be a lot easier than
doing joins particularly when you're
doing this multiple times
so in this example they pull a couple
columns
and then there's a rule where if that
record exists in a separate table
then return the value person otherwise
return the value
not a person pretty clean pretty fast
pretty easy to use
and now related to those last few
concepts it'll happen sometimes that you
need to leverage the information
inside of a table against itself and
that's where it'll be helpful to join
the table to itself
or as is commonly called the self join
here's an example
we pull the customer name column then we
pull it again
and we return instances where those two
customer names
are not the same but the city is the
same and in effect what this ends up
doing
is you're basically returning all
combinations of customers that are from
the same city
so there are more complex instances
where you're going to need to do stuff
like this but this is a simple example
that illustrates the point
all right so by this point you're
getting pretty good at sql
and you should be able to cleverly
manipulate the rows and columns of
various tables
to get a data set that's in a format
that you need it to be
now the next couple things that you need
to get familiar with
are stored procedures and udfs that is
user defined functions and these are
convenient ways of storing sql code
directly in your database
so you can use them over and over again
or at least you have that code stored so
it's there whenever you need it
and i'll have a link in the description
of this video detailing the difference
between stored procedures and functions
but they are pretty functionally similar
the single biggest difference
is that functions can be used directly
inside of statements like select and
where
whereas stored procedures cannot so
here's a really simple stored procedure
example
so they create a procedure which selects
from the table called
customers and now stored procedures can
have
optional parameters and they use those
here to set the data columns
city and postal code equal to values
that are provided when the procedure is
called
so we create this procedure and it gets
stored
and then we can use it with the exact
statement so in this example we've
stored our procedure
we execute it and then we've got our
table
and again this is a simple example but
creating these
is critical if you intend to run a chunk
of sql code over and over again
then alternatively also if you have
multiple users who are working in the
same database and you want to share your
code
it's a super convenient way to do that
next up we have window functions and
these are pretty similar to the summary
functions we talked about earlier
but these are in a class of their own
because specifically what they do
is they work on the other rows of your
table
relative to your current row one example
is lead
which pulls a value from the next row
into the current one
there's also lag that pulls a value from
the previous row into the current one
but my personal window function is row
number
so let's see an example of that so here
the first thing we're selecting is the
row number function
we order by first name and we're adding
a column for that row number
first name is aaron that gets a one
second name is abby that gets a two
so on and so forth that's all there is
to it
now you can add the partition by clause
and that's going to function kind of
like the group by statement
just as an example you could create row
numbers
again for the order of first name but
partition that by
city just as an example number nine on
this list are the useful
pivot and unpivot functions so for those
of you who are familiar with the concept
of long
and wide data pivot and unpivot are
designed to help you alternate between
the two
specifically the pivot function helps
you go from long format to wide
and the unpivot function helps you go
from wide to long format
so think of these like the spread and
gather function in the tidy r package of
r if you're familiar with that as usual
let's look at an example
so when looking at this code let's
actually start a couple lines down
so they pull two columns those are days
to manufacture and standard cost
now the average for standard cost is
taken for each value of days to
manufacture
where that variable is equal to 0 1 2
3 or 4. then the pivot function
coerces this to have one column for each
value
and there's a select statement on the
outside of this just to run the query
then if our data were just presented
like this we could use
unpivot to succinctly just get one row
per observation
so that's no problem either now you
don't necessarily
need these functions to go from one
format of data to the other
but they're going to make your life way
easier all right and for the last item
on this list
we have one that's purely performance
oriented
so it will happen if you're working with
large data sets
and particularly if you're doing things
like joins or sub queries
that your code can take several minutes
sometimes as much as
hours to run well one tool for helping
with this kind of problem
is the index think of these as like a
lookup
kind of like the index that you might
have at the back of a book
now if you were searching for multiple
things rather than scan through
every single page of that entire book if
you had that
index at the back that tells you exactly
where things appear
that's going to save you a ton of time
and that's completely analogous to what
an
index in a sql query or stored procedure
does
so if you create an index on a column
that you're searching for often
or that you're joining on you might just
dramatically speed up your query
and there's two main different types of
indexes
and those are the clustered index and
the non-clustered index
now there's a lot of difference between
the two and again that could be the
subject of its own video
so here's a good table from the website
giant stride
which i think does a decent job
comparing the pros and cons of the two
versions of indexes
and again i think rather than a data
scientist intimately knowing
all of the instances in which one is
better than the other
the absolute most important thing is
just being aware that both of them exist
to be able to look up information like
this and to be able to use either one
when necessary
and now as i promised at the beginning
of this video i'm going to throw some
resources for learning sql at your
direction
a lot of the pictures that you've seen
in this video come from w3schools.com
and this is an awesome resource for
learning tons of different programming
languages
but it's particularly nice with sql
because you can write sample code and
interact with data directly in your
browser i personally learned a lot
through the book
the guru's guide to transact sql by ken
henderson
and i'll have an amazon link to that in
the description
and then naturally there's no substitute
for practice and experience
and there's some great exercises and
challenges on the website
leet code as usual link in the
description
now once again there are tons of things
that i'm leaving off here
and one example is cursors my best
advice on when to use cursors would be
this
you don't but i really think if you know
all of this stuff
you'll be able to get your data into
virtually any format that you want
you'll be writing code at an
intermediate maybe even borderline
advanced
level you'll be able to get your code to
perform at a reasonable speed
and naturally you'll have the notions
down of writing reusable and
reproducible code
and then you're probably ready to move
on to the next big thing
maybe that's r maybe that's python maybe
it's something else
who knows the world is your oyster so
thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it and you'd like to
support my work it's super helpful for
me if you share this video
otherwise hit the like button and also
leave me a comment down below
and tell me how much sql you've used in
a data science job
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data